selon l'exécutif c'est une simple marque
de respect pour la chambre haute
mais avec le vote de jeudi au sénat
c'est bien plus qu'ils se jouent les
sénateurs en sont convaincus avec cet
article 49 4 il y à une manoeuvre
politique de la part du gouvernement
le gouvernement va dire que bien sûr une
grande considération pour le sénat
derrière on voit bien d'ailleurs dans
l'histoire c'est très rare qu'un
gouvernement utilise l'article 49 4
c'est à dire qu'il ya un vote après la
déclaration de politique générale
tout simplement parce que là j'imagine
qu'il ya peut-être une volonté de
vouloir nous diviser ou autre selon ces
sénateurs et l'air edouard philippe
serait à la manoeuvre donc pour profiter
de l'affaiblissement actuel des
républicains ce club c'est un piège
c'est pas pour nous faire plaisir
je pense que le gouvernement se dit par
les temps qui courent avec les
difficultés de la droite après les
européennes
est ce que ne pas mettre un coin entre
les républicains les centristes à
l'intérieur de chaque au pk enfin tirant
tout cas c'est une façon de mettre
devant le fait accompli de savoir si oui
ou non on va faire de l'obstruction et
être dans l'opposition
les sénateurs sont plus malins que ça
est plus ouvert d'esprit
les sénateurs à l'air qui auront la
liberté de s'abstenir ou de voter contre
jeudi et ce en fonction du contenu du
discours d'edouard philippe mai au
palais du luxembourg
un autre groupe est particulièrement
surveillé l'alliance centriste membre de
la majorité de droite et du centre du
sénat une déclaration politique générale
j'espère qu'elle aura du contenu qu elle
nous apportera des éléments de réponse
nous permettant de nous positionner
entre la confiance ou l'abstention des
sénateurs centristes qui vont se
répartir entre votre contre abstention
et vote pour les groupes us et allèrent
se réuniront une nouvelle fois demain
soir après discours du premier ministre
à l'assemblée nationale